crickets it you don't have to foul if  you're the Lakers here you play it out  there's enough of it differential  Minnesota has to score on this  possession  symbols 11 total blocks tonight goodness  Jimmy Butler are you kidding me  absolutely unconscious  his sixth triple of the game 15 now in  the quarter in the temples not only make  it a two-possession game they make it a  five-point game  [Music]  - Luke walk - is he doesn't have any  timeouts left so to do possession game  the great block by Taj Gibson really  lucky no foul was calling food was kind  of hard luck on tech on the wrists but  Jimmy gets to switch here and the  smaller rajon rondo steps up to try to  contest' the shot what a difference in  what a great screen by jeff Teague by  the way to keeping Brandon Ingram along  the law away from Jimmy Butler Butler  able to rise up over the top come Raja  Rondo and make